keep in a real lindsay lohan and they
crucified me for it oh my god did she
accept this and they made me seem like
Satan I was a bad person for holding
that brownie and that and I was so happy
to leave then go back to London after
that why would someone want to crucify
her for picking up a book and reading if
she's looking to get enlightenment
I felt really honored because of that
because she went out of her own way to
allow me to be part of her culture all
this gossiping all these negative things
they never ate with Jack
they never sat with Jack they never got
to know jack what does that tell you
they don't know jack yeah the colour of
her head start and she gave it to me and
maybe she only has two and she gave me
one there's more to that story
that occurs and I said you know what
because this woman took the time to give
me this and a part of herself not even
knowing me see what Francis Ford had to
say about the crab but if you know the
Quran the first words of the Quran the
very first I believe are something like
I'm not taking enough and and my first
thought and I and I said to you I could
friend about I said but it scares me
because people are gonna look at the
headscarf and only talk about that you
could Harvard University honoring
honoring the cried I said but it scared
me because people are gonna look at the
head so I can only talk about that it's
not that hard and it's much better than
hating that takes a lot more stress a
lot more anxiety and it's a lot harder
on your heart
you